Hallo zusammen.
Ich bin Barbara,
die eine Hälfte von "Bleisch & Bossart".
Heute möchte ich mit euch
über Alltägliches philosophieren.
Manchmal fällt mir beim Anstehen,
im Tram oder beim Coiffeur etwas auf.
Das geht euch sicher auch so.
Zum Beispiel die folgende Situation beim Parkieren:
Ich parkiere auf einem Blaue-Zone-Parkplatz.
Ich habe nur begrenzt Zeit.
Das sagt mir diese Karte.
Ich weiss aber, dass es länger geht.
Das stellt mich vor ein Dilemma:
Soll ich meinen Besuch abkürzen
und rechtzeitig zurück sein
oder eine Busse in Kauf nehmen?
Was mache ich?
Ich kenne Leute,
die schon fast ein Bussenkonto haben.
Sie bleiben immer länger in der Blauen Zone stehen
und finden, die Freiheit sei ihnen eine Busse wert.
Oder Leute, die nie ein Billett für den ÖV kaufen.
Das Geld, das sie damit sparen,
sei immer noch viel mehr als das,
was die Busse kosten würde,
wenn sie erwischt würden.
Natürlich ist das eine Form von Betrug
und Immanuel Kant würde sich im Grab umdrehen.
Wenn alle betrügen, brechen irgendwann
das System und der ÖV zusammen.
Und die Idee der Busse funktioniert nicht mehr,
wenn die Leute sie schon einberechnen.
Das zeigt Michael Sandel in seinem Buch
"Was man für Geld nicht kaufen kann"
an einem guten Beispiel:
In einem Kindergarten in Israel
holten viele Eltern ihre Kinder immer zu spät ab.
Das nervte die Angestellten verständlicherweise,
weil sie immer Überstunden machen mussten.
Irgendwann platzte ihnen der Kragen
und sie führten eine Busse ein:
Wer zu spät kommt, muss bezahlen.
Das führte aber nicht dazu,
dass weniger Eltern zu spät kamen,
sondern im Gegenteil: Noch mehr kamen zu spät.
Jetzt konnte man ja für das Zuspätkommen bezahlen.
Die Leute deuteten die Busse
also in eine Gebühr um.
Die kann man sozusagen einpreisen und sich
entscheiden, ob die Verspätung das Geld wert ist.
Michael Sandel findet,
das sei aus drei Gründen ein Problem:
Erstens diktieren dann die, die Geld haben, die Welt,
weil sie sich jede Gebühr leisten können.
Zweitens verstärkt das die Ungleichheit,
weil die Reichen sich Privilegien kaufen können,
die sich die Armen nicht leisten können.
Drittens korrumpiert es die Moral an sich,
weil man keine Sanktionen mehr aussprechen kann,
wenn jede Strafe - was eine Busse ja wäre -
in eine Gebühr umgewandelt wird.
Wie ist das bei euch
mit diesen Karten und den Bussen?
Habt ihr auch schon eine mit einberechnet
und innerlich zur Gebühr gemacht?
Zum Beispiel beim Bücherausleihen in der Bibliothek?
Welche Busse darf unter keinen Umständen
zu einer Gebühr werden?
Ich bin gespannt.
Schreibt eure Meinung in die Kommentare!
Etwas anderes, das mir auffällt,
sind Redewendungen.
Zum Beispiel höre ich wieder öfters,
dass jemand Wein trinke und Wasser predige.
Das ist ja schliesslich d e r Vorwurf der Doppelmoral:
Grossartige Reden schwingen,
sich als moralische Heldin ausgeben
und dann klammheimlich doch dem Laster frönen.
Zum Beispiel der Vegetarier, der am Grill über den
Beitrag des Fleischessens am Klimawandel predigt
und dann doch eine Wurst verdrückt,
wenn es niemand sieht.
Oder die super woke Politikerin, die für Gleichstellung
und faire Arbeitsbedingungen weibelt
und zu Hause eine Reinigungskraft
zu einem Hungerlohn schwarzarbeiten lässt.
Wer Wein trinkt und Wasser predigt,
ist zwar manchmal sympathisch,
weil allzu perfekte Leute eher abschreckend sind.
Wer sich aber mit System besser verkauft als er ist,
ist einfach unglaubwürdig
und muss sich nicht wundern,
wenn ihm bald niemand mehr glaubt.
Wer weiss, was der noch alles erzählt?
Ausserdem ist beim Wasser Predigen
vermutlich vor allem das Predigen das Problem.
Wir lassen uns nicht gerne sagen,
was wir machen sollen.
Will man uns dann noch den Spass verderben,
soll bitte der, der rummoralisiert,
selber mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen.
So denkt man zum Beispiel.
Aber was ist eigentlich, wenn keiner je bemerkt,
dass man heimlich ein Glas Rotwein stürzt?
Auch dann haben wir noch ein Problem.
Das lernen wir vom Philosophen Harry Frankfurt.
Er sagt,
menschliche Zufriedenheit habe viel damit zu tun,
dass wir in Deckung mit dem kommen,
was uns wichtig ist.
Wenn uns Wein also wirklich wichtig ist,
sollten wir auch nicht Wasser predigen müssen.
Ich hoffe, ihr könnt trinken, was ihr predigt,
und sage Prost.
Ich bin gespannt auf die Kommentare
und freue mich darauf.
Die nächste Situation: Beim Postschalter
muss man ein Ticket ziehen, um dranzukommen.
Das Prinzip ist klar: First come, first serve.
Im Supermarkt ist es meist anders:
Man steht garantiert dort an, wo es länger dauert.
Murphy's law halt. Man nervt sich.
Es stellt sich eine interessante philosophische Frage:
Ist das Prinzip "First come, first serve"
eigentlich immer gerecht? Wohl kaum.
Wenn es um Dinge geht, die nicht alle
gleich dringlich brauchen, zum Beispiel nicht.
Vielleicht Organe.
Auf der Warteliste für Spenderorgane stehen
die zuoberst, die am dringendsten eines brauchen.
Man kann also auf der Liste runterrutschen,
wenn jemand dringender eine Lunge
oder ein Herz braucht als man selber.
Wenn aber zum Beispiel zehn Patienten
dringend eine neue Leber brauchen,
wie soll man sie
in eine gerechte Reihenfolge bringen?
Bei Organen geht es immer um Fragen
der Verträglichkeit, Blutgruppen und so.
Aber sonst? Wäre es zum Beispiel okay
"die Jüngeren zuerst" zu sagen,
weil die noch am längsten
etwas von einem Organ haben
und wir es besonders tragisch finden,
wenn jemand Junges stirbt?
Das wäre aber ganz klar Altersdiskriminierung.
Gerecht ist das sicher nicht.
Oder könnten wir sagen, jemand,
der kleine Kinder hat, solle das Organ kriegen,
weil der Verlust von Mami und Papi
auch die Kinder trifft?
Das wäre auch ziemlich ungerecht
und eine Diskriminierung von Lebensformen.
Vielleicht ist das Los gerechter,
der Zufall, der blind für Sympathie ist.
Die Frage, welches Prinzip in Knappheitssituationen
gerecht ist, ist jedenfalls schwierig.
Das sehen wir auch beim Impfen:
Wer soll zuerst drankommen und warum?
Zählt das Risiko für einen schweren Krankheitsverlauf
oder die Frage,
wer mehr unter den Einschränkungen leidet?
Am Postschalter warten wir auf nichts,
das lebenswichtig ist.
Darum macht man sich nicht so viele Gedanken.
Und es geht um Güter,
die nicht knapp sind wie Organe oder Impfdosen.
Am Postschalter kommt irgendwann jeder dran,
wobei man natürlich warten muss
und Zeit verbraucht.
Und Zeit ist auch ein knappes Gut.
Müsste man nicht fragen, wessen Zeit kostbarer ist?
Was meint ihr?
Was geht euch beim Warten durch den Kopf?
Schreibt es unten hin! Ich freue mich,
wenn wir zusammen ins Philosophieren kommen.
Wollt ihr mehr von "Bleisch & Bossart",
dann abonniert unseren Kanal.
Danke und bis bald.